[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Denby
and I will be your driver on this
journey today the topic of the lecture
is going to be about one man and that
man of course is the world champion
Magnus Carlsen Magnus is currently
participating in his in a tournament
that he helped organize called the chess
masters on chess 24 and this is a
tournament that had a preliminary stage
and then a a playoff stage and in the
playoff stage
Magnus found himself on the wrong side
of the bracket sort of in the first part
of the bracket he had to face Fabiana
Cara Juana and the quarterfinals and now
he's actually just moved on past the
semi finals defeating ding Lorentz so
it's tough when your bracket consists of
the number one player the number two
player and the number three player in
the world but Magnus has really proven
some dominance at least in this rapid
chess format online against these two
biggest rivals that he kinds of faith
that he's facing currently in today's
chess world so I wanted to focus on some
of these games today and really show how
Magnus is out playing these absolutely
phenomenal chess players who are better
than literally everyone else besides
Magnus Carlsen and just see what kind of
mistakes are being made and how the
games are progressing so to start out
with I have a four move game not often
you see a form of game by players of
this level
ding lurin had the white pieces Magnus
had black and the game went c4 e6 g3
Queen g5 Bishop g2 and now I do believe
Queen takes d2 was played and Queen
takes D 2 and then Magnus resigned this
is actually something that happened -
this is not a joke
but the reason Magnus Carlsen did this
is because ding lurin actually
disconnected
round one of their match and to given
the point back magnus carlsen being the
great sportsman that he is sacrifices
coming on move four and then resigned so
i wanted to include this because it
shows how magnus is yes the best chess
player in the world right now but he's
also kind of a sportsman at it which is
making it fun to follow these games
makes it easier to be' to cheer for the
guy even when he's playing some of your
favorite players he does stuff like this
showing that he really is here trying to
play chess trying to prove that this is
still about chess not just about winning
the games winning the money and why
didn't he play Bishop takes d2 I don't
know a huge mistake from ding Lauren but
Queen takes d2 forced resignation so
good enough for me okay with that out of
the way I want to move on to some
serious games we have one here between
Fabiana Cara Juana and Magnus Carlsen so
this of course from the quarterfinal
match and I absolutely had to go over
this game because even though Fabi lost
this game he played my favorite opening
of all time which is of course the f3
nimzo-indian so whenever somebody plays
the f3 enzo at this top level I very
much want to go over the game especially
if they lose because then I have to
hurriedly you know explain away the loss
and how it's not the openings fault it's
not the openings fault so let's jump
into it here
Fabi plays d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3
Bishop before arriving at the
nimzo-indian pinning the knight to the
king and of course Fabi plays my
favorite line the f3
NIMS oh this is one that you don't see
super often at the top level these days
but honestly you don't see the nihms oh
that often these days most of the top
players now are using to avoid the
nimzo-indian with a move like Knight f3
in this position to get into more
standard Queens gambit declined theory
however Fabi
in this case happy to go for it playing
the f3 nem zone I do think it offers
white some really interesting
opportunities now just a brief aside on
the f3 NIMS oh there are many many ways
to play this at my level and I think at
most levels that are outside of the
20800 range I think the move c5 is
probably the most testing here for black
it really challenges white center forces
him to commit to this almost benoni
type of punch structure and it is a very
good version of the Benoni pawn
structure for black which is why a black
can often go for this that being said a
good version of the Benoni pawn
structure is still the benoni pawn
structure so a lot to play here too a
lot to play for here with white as as
well now you can also play d5 and go
into some pretty normal stuff you can
also play crazy moves like castles and
go for something like ninety eight and
go through this stuff although it is a
bit dubious but lately this line has
actually also gained in a bit of
popularity here the move Bishop not d6
but Bishop e7 rather is something that
is is gaining in popularity at the top
level these days as well in this case
Magnus chose none of the above
playing d5 and after a three just
capturing on c3 and now this is also a
perfectly playable line for black in the
game he played c5 and after C takes d5
if he had played he takes d5 we might be
heading for some World Championship
territory in this position actually
occurring in his World Championship
match against Vishy Anand and while that
game did end up going his way he had a
very very suspicious-looking position
for a lot of the games so not one that's
repeated off in these days instead after
C takes d5 Magnus action plays the move
Knight takes d5 and this is this line
has a pretty good reputation as being a
sort of solid try for black against this
f3 NIMS oh look Juanita doff the board
pretty quickly white for the moment is
going to actually end up with an extra
pawn for a little while but he very very
rarely is actually able to keep this
pawn and we'll see what's good opening
play black is just able to regain the
the pawn he loses so how does he lose a
pawn here well D takes c5 is simply
capturing upon blacks not really
interested in taking this guy back
allowing stuff like this in e4 coming
very very quickly so Queen a5 and now
black is so
not interested in taking this guy that
white can even play the movie for here
and he very much does
if black dares to capture on c3 just the
move Queen d2 is going to be very very
difficult to meet with a slightly
unorthodox pin but a pin none the less
on this night and if you try and move
like Queen takes e5 Bishop b2 and this
Knight is actually almost entirely
trapped here if you come back for
example this is hanging this is hanging
everything is hanging so none of this
pawn capture business just Knight f6 is
one of the main moves 97 being the other
move but Knight f6 Bishop e3 castles a4
is a little bit unorthodox Knight ft-7
and then if Bobby played the move Queen
b3 here he would be transposing into
very very very much
mainline stuff the idea being if you
capture here the move Queen before is
going to be quite awkward because you
are more or less obliged to capture this
Queen and then White gets some act of
pawns with some very great bishops or
active bishops with really great pawns
however you want to phrase it
so of course Magnus would not capture
the pawn there but here Fabi comes up
with a pretty interesting move instead
of going for Queen b3 and the normal
stuff he just plays the move King f2 and
this is a pretty interesting idea here
it is very much not preventing Knight
takes e5 as the Queen b3 does in the
normal line and so black is you know
very well within his rights to just
capture this pawn ante very much does
however Fabi does have a pretty nice
idea here he plays the move Queen d6
and the fact is this Knight doesn't
really have many comfortable squares to
go to now in the couple games that I
could find that had reached this
position before the move Knight takes a
4 was played understandably Magnus kind
of shied away from this in a rapid game
it is rather difficult to start going
pawn hunting like this with your knight
on the rim of the board putting yourself
into an incredibly awkward pin
when you don't have enough time on the
clock to really think it through so
Magnusson said it plays the move b6
which is totally fine but now white can
actually sees an advantage already out
of the opening light is going to be much
better if he finds this accurate move
here so guys in the chat room see if you
can find a way to get an advantage in
this position
Oh fallon missouri in the house go
Cardinals well thank you for watching
sound groove of America if you ever want
to make the trip down to the Chess Club
we are open now and we are open
Bishop takes c5 so Bishop takes c5
actually isn't going to do it for us in
fact why it might be lucky not to end up
worse here with in this route coming
into this open file with tempo this
Bishop is actually probably going to
come to d7 rather than b7 hitting this
a4 pawn and this nights going to get
developed without too much controversy
either so natural development for black
is is coming very very quickly even move
like Bishop a6 is potentially playable
just trading off these guys and the
black queen is going to be more active
here so you need something more concrete
than than just trading off does anybody
see it no okay
the move of course is the move Bishop b5
this is a really powerful move actually
the the point of it is you're
interfering with the Queen's protection
of the night so you are very much
threatening the move Bishop takes c5
winning another pawn black definitely
isn't really interested in going pawn
hunting here why it's going to start
developing with tempo and you're going
to be finding it very very difficult to
activate your Queen side pieces same
thing goes for a move like Knight B to
d7 just trying to develop and defend it
was like bishop c6 are already coming
and this guy is just totally stuck if
you play this move this guy's hanging
this guy's hanging it's it's gonna get
awkward rather quickly for you so here
Magnus played perhaps the most natural
move but also a move that definitely
gives white perhaps a more serious
advantage than he deserved here turns
out the move Bishop b7 might be the best
try the idea of playing a move like a
six soon for example 90 to a6 and black
is starting to kind of fight back
against the the white pieces here I move
like Queen g3 is actually potentially
playable with crazy stuff like Bishop h6
coming but this is definitely probably
one of the better ways Meghan's could
have gone here understandably in this
slightly unorthodox opening Magnus did
not have all of this prepped and chose
Bishop d7 instead which is a much more
concrete approach just trying to solve
the problem of the bishop rather
immediate
and I think this is a very human
approach you just try to get out of the
issue the most direct way possible and I
think this is a great way of playing if
you find yourself in an uncomfortable
position where you you know none of your
pieces can really move this is going to
become a bit of a theme with the games
tonight when you find yourself in these
uncomfortable positions where you can't
really move can't really develop you
should be afraid to sometimes give away
a material - to free giveaway material
specifically a pond in order to to free
the pieces and in fact Bishop d7 is
going to end up sacrificing a pond in
the ensuing line the move 92 is played
next and now Magnus goes ahead and plays
the move Bishop takes beat b5 and while
if white plays totally accurately here
white does end up with a significant
advantage if white doesn't play entirely
accurately as we see in happen in the
game then blacks pieces are finally
going to be free to be able to breathe a
little bit be able to move around a
little bit and that's that's really what
you need to get back into into a game
like this you can kind of contrast what
happened in the game Bishop takes b5
Bishop takes e5 B takes c5 and then
Queen takes e5 97 Queen b5 Queen c7 so
you can kind of contrast a position like
this I know I played through those moves
rather quickly
they were pretty forcing captures so a
position like this where white is up a
pawn but the black pieces can all move
you know this is what Magnus chose to go
for versus a position you can imagine
like Knight f d7 92 Bishop and b7 isn't
even playable like a six maybe
Bishop c6 rook a7 a position like this
where all the pieces are still on the
board black is not down upon but you see
how he just lacks you know really any
kind of coherent coordination a position
like this is much more likely to just
totally collapse and totally fall apart
in a practical game versus a position
like Magnus Scott where he is down upon
but he has active
is too you know at least be going in his
favor so that's the practical lesson to
take away I think from this opening play
is Magnus quick to sacrifice the pond
rather than play a kind of miserable
position with even material so this
should be five Bishop c5 was the
intermezzo by Fabi hitting the rook on
f8 so B takes c5 is forced now Queen
takes d5 is another nice Intermezzo
pinning the bishop to the queen 97 and
then Fabi captures on b5 with the Queen
and it does turn out and let the move a
takes b5 would have been rather powerful
for Fabi connecting the two pawns making
that extra pawn a little bit more felt
the idea that Queen takes a 1 is going
to be met with Queen takes f8 and no
major pieces are going to be lost here
for for white but a takes b5 was missed
Queen b5 played instead and now after
Queen c7 Magnus kind of gets something
he was hoping for and I'm not even sure
that white can seriously claim to be
much better here at all as we'll see in
the game he has some very practical
difficulties with specifically this King
and this extra pawn sitting on c3 is not
really going to be felt in in this exact
position what would happen after a6
directly well let's go back and take a
quick look if a 6 directly I think this
is a playable move I think somehow
someway there's some crazy business
involving the move 92 and if this piece
gets captured then this piece gets
captured and if this piece gets captured
then this piece gets captured and all of
a sudden the rooks are connected and you
have an issue on the a8 square so some
some funny tactics like this but after
this maybe Bishop e7 and then you end up
with similar stuff with crazy Queen g3
business Bishop back to d3 also
potentially being playable I think it
transposes in in most cases to be honest
just - Bishop e7 first good question
though
moving along rook H to d1 is the natural
move by Fabi getting the work out of the
corner allowing
King to step back to the first rink and
now simply 95 by Magnus stepping off of
the square where the knight was attacked
getting the knight to active squares
looking to just activate the pieces and
this is how you should play of course
with active pieces when you're down
material you don't need to essentially
to immediately rather try and regain
this material you kind of at any cost
it's more just about getting your pieces
into the game getting them to good
squares like a 5 like c4 and taking your
time with it it's it's not all about the
material a lot of it is just about
finding squares for your pieces rather
than let this night sit on the e5 square
Fabia actually chose to push f4 which
has a lot of upsides
but unfortunately has a lot of downsides
as well well see now that's in addition
to having pressure on White's extra pawn
white is really going to struggle with
this King and Magnus is quick to take
advantage of that he plays the move
Knight g4 check and Bobby comes up to
King f3 now it was possible to play a
move like h5 and sort of leave this
Knight here but Magnus decided that this
night would be better suited attacking
the newly weakened e4 square from f6 now
Queen e5 was played in the game Queenie
7 is magnus carlsen choice and rook up
to d4 is very very natural by Fabi just
preparing to double solidifying the e4
square as well the rook comes over to c8
still all about piece activity here for
black rook b1 Ric FD 8 gets the final
piece into the position it takes takes
Queen d4 now of course as black you're
down upon you have the safer King not
interested in trading these Queens off
this I think might be just strictly
losing so Queen c7 instead and once
again you see how there's just these
soft points in the white camp and Magnus
isn't breaking through on these soft
points immediately but he is just
applying pressure just applying pressure
to each and every one of these squares
and making white sort of play around
them you know if white wants to make
any type of progress he's going to have
to always keep an eye on all of these
weak squares that that black is
targeting the move rook t1 was played in
the game notably this night is tied down
to the defense this Queen tied down to
the defense sort of only leaves this
rook left over to move around freely sir
rook t1 and now once again
Magnus doesn't go crazy doesn't get
impatient being down the pond he plays a
simple improving move h6 you know it's
this type of patients that really ends
up winning
Magnus this game you know it's it's not
about immediately regaining the material
it's not about going for things like
Queen I five trying to break through
with things like this it's not about
trying to play crazy moves like g5
trying to get at the king it's about
playing simple improving chess and
relying on your position to sort of take
care of itself in the game Fabi actually
goes a little bit wild and plays the
move g4 in Magnus plays the slightly
strange looking Rick e8 perhaps aiming
for some e5 ideas and once again taking
a look at the squares that Fabi weakened
with g4 and trying to take advantage of
them with the move like a5 Queen d6 was
played in the game and now Queen c4 you
know sort of as soon as Fabi abandons
the defense of one of these weak points
this is when Magnus steps in to apply
more pressure here sort of remind Fabi
that hey you know you want to try to get
active well keep an eye on all these
weaknesses that you made and so Fabi
very quickly a justice queen back to
this back to the be Foursquare rather
than the d4 square but still in a very
defensive position just guarding the
weak squares Queen see it was played by
Magnus and 93 was fabi's choice I'm
going for some stuff on the Kings side
and now Magnus takes his opportunity to
play the move e5 e five more or less
forces white to play the move f5 if you
just ignore it
of course I'm going to take this and now
this King is it's really looking dire so
f5 played in the game and now from here
Magnus actually plays the mover of d8
offering up another Brook trade and this
goes to show you once again how patient
Magnus is and how unafraid of the extra
pond he is in a position like this the
extra pond really doesn't matter and
that's kind of the the story of of this
game now let me paint you a very
different picture where black waste to
Tempe and this pond lands on c5 now all
of a sudden the extra pond very very
much does matter and this is sort of the
the point of the whole game is when your
pawns on c3 it's not a very useful extra
pawn when the pawns on c5 that's when
your opponent has to start really really
being careful this third ranked fourth
versus the the fifth rank makes a huge
huge difference so if you find yourself
playing with the extra material you
should very much strive to get this pawn
up the board as quickly as you can so
that it can be making tangible threats
in the position now we saw White's
pieces being tied down to weaknesses
around the king that were made but as
soon as this pawn reaches a square like
the fifth rank now it's going to be
blacks pieces tied down making sure this
pawn does in advance even further and
you know become an unstoppable
unstoppable Queen so that's the lesson
of this game is one this patience that
Magnus is showing just keeping an eye on
weaknesses not rushing things trying to
win the material back and two when your
extra pawn is so far back it is still an
extra pawn but it's not going to
contribute to the game unless eventually
you can get it to roll up the board so
Rick d8 played in the game offering a
trade of the rooks which Fabi accepts
but now the point is these squares
become pretty much impossible to to
defend turns out the move Queen b1 would
have been fine for Fabi take keeping an
eye on these two squares exactly but
it's not good for any more and then
equality unfortunately moves like Queen
c4 I think also get the job done just
coming back to square like e 2 but in
the game Bobby just blunders with the
move King
and now with this one simple mistake by
Fabi Magnus has been playing more or
less perfect chess since and getting
that slight disadvantage out of the
opening and now Magnus seizes the
advantage the second the opportunity is
offered and goes on to win this game
pretty cleanly so King me - of course
drops this pawn on g4 which Magnus of
course captures an ID f1 was Bobby's
choice and now I'd like you to try and
find try and try and find Blacks next
move it's a very very clever move and
I'll be very impressed if you guys do
end up finding the move that Magnus
played here it is actually just the best
move by far and it's definitely not one
that would have come to come to my mind
at first glance
so wait to move and get a significant
advantage
so everybody in the grandmother would
play the move Queen h4 here right of
course you're attacking these dark
squares you're attacking h2 and you're
threatening to suggest invade but of
course there is the subtlety where Queen
be a check and queen takes a seven is
defending f2 as well as clearing the
path for an ape on winning yet another
pawn for white and while black might be
doing ok here black is definitely not
going to win this position without this
pawn so that's why Magnus plays the move
a5 says hey how about you move that
Queen and once Bobby does of course now
Queen h4 is is coming through with
devastating effect if Queen c5 were
played instead trying to guard some of
these squares still Queen h4 is going to
be very very strong and now if Queen
takes a five it's less good than Queen
takes a 7 because Queen f2 check is
going to be brutal and if white you know
doesn't take the bait plays a move like
c4 Queen h5 is gonna be really strong I
think 9 f6 should be pretty strong as
well hitting me for even a move like
King age 7 and white is almost
completely in zoogs Vung in the game
though Queen B 5 and now Queen h4 is
just devastating Knight d2 was played
and Queen takes h2 with check comes on
the board king d3 queen g3 with check
King c2 93 with check King b3 Queen e1
is just corralling this King now all the
way on the Queen side Queen d3 was
played to protects Queen d1 check now
comes on the board King a to Queen takes
a 4 check King B to played in the game
and I do remember there was a very very
funny line shown on the livestream here
that went Knight d1 check King b1 and
then I'd like you guys to find white to
move and and and win it's it's a bit
unnecessary but it is it is pretty fun
note that 91 check didn't actually
happen in the game but would have been
fun if it did
how could Fabi blender like that time
trouble I don't think he was in super
severe time trouble he might have been a
little bit low on time I don't actually
recall the exact time time clock black
to move yeah I'm that black to move I'm
sorry I'm sorry if I was saying the
wrong thing yes Oh Queen b5 Queen B five
is the funny way to do it of course like
everything is winning here but but Queen
b5 is the funny way to do it but
unfortunately the move Queen c2 or King
c2 does exist if Queen takes b5 was
forced then this would be the funniest
but King c2 you can't just take on d3
play a4 and this end game is just quite
clearly going to be winning king c2 just
means a move like 93 check and with both
rook pawns running up the board white
very much does not stand a chance here
so this didn't happen in the game
unfortunately but Knight g4 was played
instead Knight b3 and now black is just
up too many pawns Queen e7 more checks
and the a pawn starts running up the
board Queen a4 check was enough for
resignation with a 2 and a 1 pretty much
being unstoppable to follow so this was
a really interesting game by Magnus
Carlsen and it shows what Magnus can do
when he's when he's on Form you know it
almost doesn't matter
and that Fabi got such a good position
out of the opening had the chance for
such an advantage because Magnus quite
frankly just just sort of outplayed him
from that middle game position you know
Fabi was trying various things starting
to push some pawns but it turned out
that he was just over pressing because
Magnus is position was active he was
patient he had good pieces and that's
all you really need in a chess game like
this so notes to take away note how
Frenkel useless this c3 pawn was too
white how the only way it's ever going
to be relevant is if it manages to march
up the board I can't find this game yeah
I'm pretty sure this one was from their
quarterfinal match
but maybe it was somehow from the
preliminary stage I don't know
regardless it's the f3m so I had to go
over it points to take away this pawn
useless and see three incredibly useful
on c5 I'm not saying Fabi like missed an
opportunity to push this pawn up the
board but as a general rule of thumb
with extra pawns keep this in mind the
further back they are the less important
they are and sometimes you'll see that
in positions where somebody has like
plucked off an H pawn it almost becomes
kind of irrelevant in a lot of V
positions because often the counter part
is sitting on h2 not not doing too much
at all other things to keep in mind when
you're down material in a situation like
this it's not necessarily all about
regaining that material it's just about
keeping your pieces happy making sure
they stay active making sure they all
have useful roles and then that's quite
often enough to have a decent
compensation as in this game rapid
rating from some of the classical ones
these are the ratings that likely chess
throws up so that you know that's that's
what I used as well anyways moving along
I wanted to take a look now at a game
from the semi-final match that just
concluded today that Magnus played
against ding Lorenz so you know world
number two out of the way crushed him in
the quarterfinals now on to the world
number three and this is Magnus up
against England so let's jump into it
here
we had c4 c5 g3 d5 and this is already a
bit unusual by Magnus much more common
as Knight f6 Bishop g2 d5 see d5 and now
95 the point being we play Knight f6
first to be able to recapture with the
knight and then after Knight c3 this
Knight comes back to b6 so rather than
go for this mainline stuff and yet d5
Queen takes d5 Knight f3 knight c6 and
Knight c3 Queen back to d8 and while it
looks as though black is sort of just
wasting extra time moving this Queen out
and back if you compare these positions
this is the main line this is the
in magna Scott so once again mainline
position he got it turns out it's not so
different after all right
white developed a night instead of a
bishop and that's kind of all the time
that that black actually lost here so
not a ridiculous idea out of the opening
for Magnus the main difference is this
night it's gonna be on f6 now rather
than b6 there are some upsides to this
there are also some downsides to this
that we'll see Dingle Aaron actually
tries to take advantage of them but it
doesn't end up really making making a
difference here or ding so kingside
castles by white we have now h6 and by
black and this is one of those key
differences that I wanted to highlight
quite often in this main line which I'm
going to jump back to once again you'll
actually see the move f6 and getting
played eventually for example let me
just play some moves eight three castles
before there should be six Rick b1 and
f6
this is a position that's been reached
over a thousand times this is sort of
the structure that black aims for
supporting the e5 pond with this f6 push
giving this bishop a square and back on
f7 and keeping those bishops kind of
casually placed behind at the e pawn
looking out peeking out at the board and
so of course that structure is not going
to be possible with this knight on f6 so
you see this pawn come to h6 instead
because controlling the g5 square really
is going to be critical here now we see
the move d3 and we arrive at another
difference from the main line that the
world-champion place rather than bring
this bishop out to e7 it is in this case
going to be much better placed on the d6
square so who knows why the bishop on d6
is better than the bishop on e7 thanks
to the difference in the opening line
can you guys in the chat figure this one
out
why is d5 unusual well it's unusual
because this Queen d5 Queen d8 line is
is not very well known it's pretty
counterintuitive to bring the Queen out
and then bring it directly back right
away
Joe Bruin does not know why so in the
alternate line I promise we'll stop
skipping back and forth pretty soon in
the alternate line we have of course
this pawn coming to f6 to defend the e5
pawn so we never really have to worry
about the e5 Punk's the pawn is always
defending it now in this land of course
we don't have this luxury so we do
actually have to give our e5 pawn some
consideration here which is why the
bishop comes out to d6 just providing
some extra support to the e5 pawn
compensating for the fact that f6 is no
longer a serious option here for black
now the pawn comes out to a 3 and we see
another difference from the main main
line here rather than allow b4 Magnus
does actually take the time to play the
move a5 and I think this is probably a
good decision here by Magnus notably if
he did not do this and simply castled
this pawn comes to b4 if you play a
simple move like Bishop e6 already
actually you're running into quite a bit
of trouble with a move like b5 and
Bishop b2 to follow the point being this
guy is suddenly becoming quite difficult
to defend and you might find yourself
when you play moves like 97 and b6 which
if that's the case you likely should
have stepped spent these Tempe earlier
on in the opening when you could have
done it for for free so because of that
Magnus I believe plays the move a5
hampering the b4 break and while memento
mori has typed out a whole plethora of
reasons why the bishop belongs on d6 and
most of them I think are quite true it
does also leave the e-file open which is
the main addition that that he was
saying that I failed to mention
and because the e-file is left more open
moves like 94 do come a little bit
easier in the game now dinger n shows a
slightly more cautious approach a
slightly more slower approach to the
position but do
to Black's opening play he has you know
all these advantages having this bishop
on d6 opening the e-file allowing this
Knight to potentially jump to d4 but
they weren't they weren't free they
definitely weren't free so who sees some
potential ideas here for white the move
b3 was played in the game and I'm not
gonna argue that b3 is a bad move I
think b3 is a perfectly fine move it was
potentially maybe even the best move but
it doesn't really aim to punish blacks
opening play per se
well this isn't quite the same as as the
Scandinavian line Lorenzo it's pretty
different when you arrive from from the
English chess space Arabia says Bishop T
295 in b4
jarda says Knight b5 is in santa slayer
will say the move d4 so in this specific
case the move I was fishing for was in
fact this move d4 this highlights the
fact that this bishop went to d6 rather
than e7 of course on d6 it leaves the
e-file open but on e7 it left and the D
file opens so this is sort of a unique
opportunity that white generally doesn't
get in this opening this early on this
opportunity to play d4 and if white can
achieve d4 very often why it should be
playing the move d4 and the game might
continue with a series of captures and
kingside castles and then white might
just have a comfortable position after
move like Kirk d1 where black is sort of
feeling the pressure of the white major
pieces on this open file other things
the chat room was saying include the
move Knight B 5 Bishop d2 and b4 and I'm
not a huge fan of this Bishop b2 and
Bishop d2 and B 4 idea to be totally
honest I think that opening a file may
actually tend to favor black in this
position but the move Knight b5 is very
very relevant and I think it's a very
very important idea for white in this
position and we'll see that come into
play a little bit later on and the
reason I p5 is so important isn't so
much because it opens up this diagonal
but more so yes it attacks this bishop
on d6 but more importantly it defends
the d4 square and we'll see that this
opening line does often turn out to be
all about the d4 square
be three played in the game castles as I
was saying Bishop b2 now and rook e8 so
Magnus is making use of this efile to
the fullest extent now rook c1 was
played in the game and I think this is
this is a perfectly fine move this move
is actually for the moment preventing
the move Knight d4 I believe because
takes takes in ninety five is likely and
just going to be strong with all of the
white pieces sort of coming together a
bit to harmoniously so 94 not really on
the cards for the moment Bishop h3 was
played instead and now I do sort of
believe that this is where things
started to go wrong for ding lorente on
the surface this looks like a pretty
quiet position with not too many you
know sort of direct threats coming
through on the board immediately
but this is kind of the moment when you
know somebody is going to be declared
the victor of the opening not
necessarily the game but this is where
it's going to be decided who has the
better position out of the opening in
the next very few moves and the reason
for that is both sides are threatening
very concrete ideas not to win material
but yes to get a good positional
advantage so is anybody here familiar
with these positions and does anybody
here know these positional threats that
that both players are aiming for
of course I've I've talked a bit about
ideas for black I've talked a bit about
ideas for white but there's one specific
idea for white in general that I'm
hoping you guys will manage to find and
one idea for for black as well that
should hopefully already be in your mind
so try and come up with these positional
threats that are sort of beginning to
appear in in the position positional
threats
let's goodbye to Joe goodbye who has any
positional threats
I get the feeling that memento mori is
our resident English expert in the chat
so I better know what I'm talking about
because I don't often play this opening
line
but I do claim to know a little bit
about it santa slayer i'm not sure what
you mean by e5 if you mean this pawn
this pawn is on e5 yes analyzer games
will be happening at 8 p.m. Central time
today on Twitch but we do have one more
class in between this one and that one
Manny says III d4 maybe Beltran says
night b5 Gigi says night h4 so you guys
have a lot of the ideas there are some
positional features that are really
important that you're pointing out one
is yes this Bishop is a huge benefit to
- white white is definitely playing for
some long term pressure with this Bishop
and this Bishop is actually the reason
for blacks positional threat that I want
to talk about but that's not really the
the huge positional idea that that white
is trying to get through so let me
explain the positional idea that white
once with a variation that I want to
show and then first let me talk about
blacks position line DX it's a little
bit easier to understand so we do see
this bishop kind of bearing down on the
Queen side and we do see that the b v
square is a significant hole for for
black here so if you imagine that white
sort of waste some time like h3 Queen d7
King edge - now all of a sudden the move
Knight d4 is the really crucial idea for
black and that's magnus carlsen is very
much trying to achieve and the point is
after 92 black is now able to solve all
of his problems with one move and that
move
is c6 and actually this is exactly how
the game variation continued magnus
carlsen got all of these moves in and
while on the surface it might not look
like white is doing terribly here this
is in fact going to be practically just
a significantly much more comfortable
position for black if something isn't
done sort of immediately to counter out
counteract this setup this is a huge
positional game for black being able to
play c6
and remove this knight from this
diagonal and yes the knight on d4 looks
looks you know pretty as well but the
knight on d4 isn't really the main point
the main point is we stunt this bishop
and block this knight from the b5 square
because black has achieved this black
should have seriously no issues for kind
of the rest of this game now I want you
to contrast what happened in the game if
met ding Lauren had played the move
Knight b5 here now obviously I can't say
for certain how the game would have
continued but if you imagine that the
game continues along similar lines for
example now the move Knight d4 isn't
really on the cards because we've
defended that square quite adequately so
a move like Queen d7 you know trying to
activate the bishops then just for
example a move like Queen c2 applying
more pressure to c7 further discouraging
the move Knight d4 and defending this
diagonal just a bit then maybe a move
like Bishop h3 move like rook FD one
captures captures and then a simple move
like Erick hd8 now all of a sudden out
of nowhere
White's positional threat can sort of
break through and that threat is yes
there was one powerful Bishop Black has
managed to neutralize that with his play
but don't forget there's actually a
second very very powerful Bishop in the
position for white and that threat is to
play the move d4 if white can achieve
the move d4 without too much controversy
then white should significantly I
believe be better in this position in
some specific cases if black had played
for example even a bit worse you know
played a sort of nonchalant move like
I don't know let's just say he wastes
some time Rick d8 Rick d1 and I don't
know King AJ now all of a sudden moves
like Eve for also potentially become
playable and then d4 even becomes
stronger with the fact that these Center
pawns are now sort of rolling up the
board so positional threats for white
definitely the move d4 is number one
priority for white the reason being you
absolutely want to open up this second
bishop and you want to prevent moves
like 94 kind of by occupying that square
yourself taking that space for yourself
before your opponent can't can sort of
get there so a positional idea for black
definitely this move Knight d4
positional idea for white playing D for
himself or for d4 or occasionally III d4
as as many even suggested so keep those
ideas in mind if you find yourself in
these sorts of positions this is kind of
one of the most common ways that you'll
you'll see players playing against the
English not necessarily this exact
position but setups like this for black
with this sort of imbalance with the
knight 180 to come to d4 and white
trying to control the long diagonal like
this these are the really key ideas to
know here but okay in the game Age 3 was
played by Daniel Aaron and I really do
think that this move was a critical
mistake because it allowed black too
much time to get the setup that he
wanted Queen d7 with tempo King eh - and
now 94 and now though the worst is
definitely passed for Magnus and I do
believe black just has a very very
comfortable position 90 to c6 and then
dink goes for this move III already
there's some potential tactical ideas of
taking on d3 and giving up two pieces
for the rook and a couple pawns but
Magnus wasn't having it plays the move
Knight b5 instead the knight takes b5 C
takes b5 and now while it's true that
the diagonal has kind of been opened up
the removal of the c6 Knight very much
works in blacks favor rather than white
here and white didn't get to play this
for free he had to commit to the move
III and because now he's committed to
the move III this pawn on d3
is going to be a significant weakness in
fact because this pawn in d3 is so weak
we'll see ding Lauren actually give up
kind of his entire queenside just in an
attempt to maintain this pawn Knight f3
was played in the game trying to defend
the d4 square also supporting this pawn
from behind Rick a d8 now and once again
ding has to make a concession here plays
the movie for this is sort of the only
way to really keep this deep on from
dropping off the board Bishop e6 was
magnus carlsen choice now this is kind
of a pawn sacrifice on e5 but we'll see
that it was just very well calculated by
the world champion and he does end up
with a a fairly significant advantage in
the game
ding captured on e5 and ended up in some
trouble can anybody guess the best move
for white in this position can anybody
see a 95 is an idea to remember it's not
the most intuitive so in this case 95
was so strong because the move a5 has
been played and this actually happens
quite a bit when the moves a5 or vice
you know or a4 kind of appear on the
board then that's when 95 in night
before respectively can become very very
strong because normally a three and a
six are just too comfortable for kicking
away the night but once these pawns have
sort of been committed that's when the
these moves kind of gain in power
why not d4 instead of E for 90 for a
Knight takes e5 I'm so taking the knee 5
is actually what the world champion was
hoping for either with the knight or the
bishop
last chance for d4 so d4 is is gonna be
correct here I think d4 is the best try
for white the point being you just need
to get rid of this this week pawn sort
of any cost the game might continue
Knight takes e4 Queen e2 Knight back to
g5 and then white is regaining this pawn
on the e5 square so d4 would have been
nice also would have been thematic once
again the point being we just need to
open up this bishop in the game ding
Lauren actually goes for Bishop takes e5
and now after Bishop takes e5 and Knight
takes d5 Queen d6 this is a simple fork
and the the walls sort of come tumbling
down for white here f4 was a nice move
to support this night but now Queen
takes a 3d for Bishop takes be three and
three Queen side pawns are rolling very
very quickly whereas white Center is not
so easy to mobilize with the black rooks
so well-placed to kind of challenge
their advance and Dingley run kind of
fell apart rather quickly in this
position Queen d3 has played Queen b4
ding tries to push the D pawn this rook
comes to c8 challenging the open file
also rook c8 was a bit of a trap
actually by Magnus Carlsen it very much
is daring white to play
d6 threatening to fork these rooks and
ding kind of accepted the bait but now
only one move wins for black but it does
in fact when and Magnus finds it we just
played rook D to c8 in the winning move
is of course to play rook C to d8 just
challenging this pawn and once again and
now there's there's simply no way to to
defend this pawn the D 1 square is
covered d7 isn't enough Knight takes D 7
played in the game and it takes D 7 and
now Bishop c4 is just devastating know
where to put this Queen Queen D 1 this
is hanging this is hanging this is
hanging it's just a lost position Queen
D 1 Queen e7 and ding Lauren
threw in a towel here went ahead and
just resigned so we saw that game sort
of turn very very very quickly into
Magnus Carlson's favor and the reason is
that early middle game that one slight
misstep with h3 sort of was the the
first domino in the series of mistakes
that that led to Magnus winning this
game I do think h3 in this position is
more or less the culprit for Magnus
Carlsen winning this game
and it goes to show you how dangerous
these kind of innocuous-looking
positions actually can be just because
you know neither side is getting
checkmate it immediately doesn't mean
that there isn't a lot at stake in fact
I would go as far as to say that this
position is terrifying to me because if
you waste just a little bit too much
time all of a sudden you are going to be
in a world of suffering for a long long
time one last positional note on this
after 94 you might be wondering why
Knight d2 allowing black the time to
play the move c6 why not take on d4 take
on d4 and the reason is this structure
is also just going to be very very
advantageous to to black if black can
manage to get this half-open e file with
this rook bearing down on this e to pawn
white is once again going to be
suffering
in this position just for example I move
like nine a four and then I don't know I
guess this is sort of a problem but not
really because we're threatening this
yeah I don't know I move like Bishop e6
even and life is is going to be good for
for black hairy ideas of Bishop d5 ideas
of rook b8 if you dare it to capture
this guy if you play move like 95 you
can just take in to Queen d6 and the
Queen slide is very very mobile for
black this is just a good structure for
black in general okay so one last note
on that game so II for was the turning
point I go I would go as far as to say
that Age 3 was the turning point because
after age 3 94 became unstoppable for
black and if black achieves 94 that
black is doing very very well in these
positions even if you know objectively
the computer says it's not that bad for
white practically once 94 comes on the
board white is very very much on the
back foot and we saw here
I believe that Bishop takes d5 was the
point where Magnus actually did get a
very serious advantage if white had
found the move d4 here I think white is
still doing doing ok ok we have seven
minutes left
why don't we take a look at one more
game hopefully I will move quickly in
this one this is another game of ding
lurin against Magnus Carlsen we had d4
in a king's indian from the world
champion and as I take a sip Knight of
three castles h3 is the fashionable
thing to do these days with the way
pieces against the King's Indian and the
idea of h3 is sort of multi fold in some
of the more positional lines you'll see
black trying to trade off this bishop
for one of the the light pieces for
white now this won't happen in your more
traditional Kings Indian where this
bishop is really important but in some
lines you'll see white go for a more
Benoni type or black go for a more of an
Oni type setup and that's when you would
kind of see
those ideas coming into play so it
guards the G Foursquare against that
guards the G Foursquare against any
annoying night g-force if this bishop
comes to III but perhaps most
importantly it guards the the G
Foursquare so that white could
potentially put upon their and the idea
of this is of course one of the main
breaks in the King's Indian for black is
always you know II 5f5 challenging the
center and g4 is a very nice deterrent
of f5 so h3 this is the thing to do
these days are the semies over yet
I believe Anish Gary and yon diploma she
still have more to go in their battle
they are tied one to one in the mini
matches Magnus has defeated England to
move on to the finals if I've played in
the game d5 Knight a6 was the world
champions choice the point being you
just want to get this Knight into the c5
square and now Bishop g5 is a kind of
annoying move by ding lorente the huge
downside of playing the move h3 is that
you very much weaken the f4 square
you're kind of limiting your potential
to play the move g3 so Bishop g5 is a
nice way to compensate for that by
making this night slightly more in
Mobile Bishop d7 was played in the game
by Magnus Knight back to d2 now is
freeing up this F pawn for anything you
might want to do might want to come to
f3 might not want to move at all maybe
we just want some access for our Queen
to these kinds of squares c6 played in
the game is challenging the center Irish
ever-so-slightly
for black this should be - Queen b6 rook
over to be 1 King h8 now was played by
Magnus and I think this is because
Magnus was running a little bit short on
ideas this Queen I feel like doesn't
really belong on this b6 square I think
this is actually a little bit of a
misstep walking into things like a
potential c5 over the tempo a potential
Knight c4 with tempo potential b4 c5
with tempo but oh well
King h8 castles and now c5 played by
Magnus and this was I think in direct
response to some threats involving c5
in 95 with with tempo or 94 with tempo
for for white a three queen d 8 B 4 B
six night be 5 was played in the game we
need 7 now force to defend the e pawn or
the D pawn and I'm not gonna lie to you
this is kind of just an awful awful
awful position for black out of the
opening
dinkler and definitely outplayed Magnus
in the opening here but the point of the
game I'm arriving at shortly comes a
little bit later a Bishop d3 Queen of
fate 9f one 9h 593 ship f6 Magnus comes
up with this maneuver because he just
wants to fire it off his bad piece in
general of course he wants to trade
pieces because he has less space but he
makes sure that those trades aren't on
unfavorable form getting rid of this
bishop which was staring at nothing but
pawns for whites active bishop
we have takes takes Knight c3 Queen back
out to e7 Bishop c2 now and we had we
even see the move Knight B 8 by Magnus
trying desperately to get this Knight
back into the game Queen d2 was played
by ding Lauren King g7 and now we see
dings sort of give Magnus his his shot
to get back into the game so I'm gonna
ask you two questions question number
one the move King age 2 was played in
the game find the shot for Magnus to
give your pieces life once again we
don't care about material we care about
having you know squares for our pieces
having active pieces so black to move
and free his pieces even at the expense
of some material what can you do with
black here
all right I don't have a ton of time so
if you do want to find it for yourself
go ahead and pause the video here if not
the solution of course is you want to
take on before it takes before and play
the move a5 and what's the point of all
this one we are opening up this C file
for our rook more importantly - we are
getting rid of the final defenders of
the c5 square and once those defenders
are gone we're back baby coming back
into the c5 square our Knight has a
square and we are back in the game
rook a 1 played in the game is
threatening to win this pawn so of
course magnus carlsen gravels and plays
the move Bishop Yeats saying please
don't take my pawn but that's a joke of
course of course he just sacrifices this
a pawn because who cares about the a
pond we got the c5 squared for our
Knight that's all we wanted that's all
we wanted so bi 5 ba v rook a five-night
c5 and now all of a sudden the horrible
horrible position that's black used to
have is now actually not the most
uncomfortable position I've ever seen in
my life I think in general you might
prefer to be white here just because of
the extra pawn still but honestly
practically it's easier to find moves
for the black pieces here there's open
files your Knights are on good squares
you have targets on e4 and c4 and the
moves sort of just flow naturally and
this is another case as we saw in Game
one of Magnus using these active pieces
to just outplay his opponent despite
being material down so and that's how
black managed to break free and as for
what white could have done about it I do
think that's the computer suggestion
here of b5 is actually correct now you
have to be wary in these kinds of
positions sometimes the computer will
suggest a move like b5 and it totally
locks down the entire Queen side which
is not what you want the computers kind
of just wrong about these positions it's
one of the few things that it's often
wrong about you want the ability to open
at least one file on the Queen side you
don't want it totally locked down but b5
doesn't do that and the reason is if the
move a5 comes on the board first of all
9 a 4 is going to be good enough just
totally decimating this beep on but also
be a 6 is going to be a very comfortable
edge now for white the reason being even
though we're not up upon here and we
still are activating some of the black
pieces this pawn still remains on c5 and
we have a target on on b6 so I think b5
would have been great with the idea to
follow that if black continues kind of
shuffling while the move a5 is is going
to become strong eventually you know
even if not straight away we can
definitely prepare this move it moves
like okay one moving it on c3 but this
idea of a 5 and 8 takes b6 is I think
going to be a strong one so very quickly
let's see how the game wrapped up that's
how I think Dean could have improved and
kept the advantage we saw Magnus slowly
making threats on the kingside keeping
an eye on the Queen side as well the
Queen came back to g5 all the way back
to the Queen side ding starts pushing
this F pawn which will see it kind of
comes back to bite him
he comes ends up lacking a bit in King
safety this pawn comes to g4 the Kings
side closes up a bit and now what the
king of side closed both players turn
their total attention over to the Queen
side Knight b5 perhaps was a pretty
important mistake by ding now with this
pawn being drawn to the be 5 square his
king is actually a little bit too weak
with pressure along this 4th rank coming
to him
we had Bishop takes b5 cb5 Queen a4 and
now you do see this pressure starting to
mount on the e4 pawn ding Treg repeating
for a bit and eventually we ended up in
this position where the only move for
ding to actually maintain equality is
the strange-looking night to d1 just
stepping off the f2 square so you could
meet rook b3 with a move like okay one
the point being this Queen is overloaded
but in the game ding chose the move
Queen b3 which is of course just
immediately tactically losing on the
spot so black to move and win if you
want to try to find it if not of course
the move is rook c1 and the point is
this rook is simply overworked
and after Rick Siwon Dingley Ren went
ahead and resigned in this position and
so with this Magnus goes on to win the
semifinal match against ding taking out
Fabiano Kara wanna in the quarterfinals
taking out dangler end in the
semi-finals moving on to play the finals
either against Anish Giri who he's been
having some fun trash talk with or Jana
poha she who is one of the frontrunners
in the candidates to challenge him for
the world championship title should be
an exciting finale to the tournament
hopefully you guys enjoyed these games
with Magnus Carlsen I think they really
show how he is still the you know sort
of number one player in the world out
playing the number two and three players
and very convincingly in both of these
matches that is it for the road to 2000
tonight if you're watching live be sure
to stay tuned we've got the endgame
class coming up right after this if
you're watching the video that is all
for me tonight thank you so much for
joining me my name is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]